those interviews for whatever reason i
have not been hired and which is okay
because
at the end of the day i still have an
opportunity to go out there and help our
team
to pursue and obtain our goal and so yes
there is a focal point where you're
focused on that interview but once that
interview was over now it's time to turn
the page you know i can't sit here and
dwell in pity you know because when it's
all said and done when i have a
responsibility to the kansas city chiefs
i have a responsibility to coach reid i
have a responsibility to this entire
offensive coaching staff and our players
to make sure that we're mentally and
physically ready to go come game day but
that's who i am
okay and that's how i operate
[Music]
well that sounds like a guy who doesn't
interview well to me
uh
really i mean that's great but it's
great yeah that that and that that's it
that's it in a nutshell and it was
communicated very clearly very plainly
very persuasively and it supports one of
the points that we make from time to
time just
just stop all of the coaching searches
don't even start them until after the
super bowl so you don't put guys in the
spot where you know you're worried about
your your team your current team right
you're also worried about whether or not
you're going to get a new job and
someone explained to me not that long
ago when uh when the coach goes home at
night assuming he's married
on a on a tuesday in advance of a
playoff game
mrs coach isn't going to say how's the
game plan coming for sunday mrs coach is
going to say if you heard anything about
whether or not you're going to get this
job right as a head coach somewhere else
that becomes a top priority and it puts
guys in a tough spot but you know chris
something that andy reid said yesterday
makes a ton of sense i wrote about it
after i saw the quote
he said i talked and i'm paraphrasing
here but i talked to a lot of owners and
general managers and team presidents who
were looking for coaches about eric i
gave them input
i am looking forward to finding out from
them
why he didn't get hired
and i hope that he does make those calls
and say tell me why and this dovetails
was something someone suggested last
week
every candidate and especially the black
candidates who are not being hired at
the same rate as their white
counterparts they should know they
should be told they should have a right
to know what it was that kept them from
being hired is it an interview issue if
so tell me what i need to do better how
do you get better they say well the
interview experience you get better you
get better well now if you keep doing
the same thing over and over again you
need feedback right and the people who
didn't hire you as to why they didn't
hire you and how you need to address
whatever you need to address so you do
get hired that's only fair so i like
what coach reid said and i hope that the
league pushes these teams if not
requires these teams to give real
feedback as to why the candidates for
these jobs aren't getting them because
there are some that stand out and i feel
bad for eric b enemy who's become the
focal point of this he doesn't want that
he doesn't deserve that but it just kind
of happens when a guy who clearly is
qualified
and and you get and no disrespect to
david cully i can't reconcile
eric the enemy not being hired and a guy
who's never been a coordinator whose
name has never been mentioned
as a head coaching candidate anywhere
right right it's the job in houston i
can't reconcile the two chris no well
you shouldn't i mean it's he's not in
the same stratosphere as eric b enemy i
mean just the way it looks i mean to me
i mean that's just you know my honest
opinion especially what eric b enemy is
doing you know on the offensive side of
the ball the way he talks again every
time you hear him he handles himself to
a way where i just go
i'd play for him i don't understand
what's going on i love andy reid you
know he's going to get to the bottom of
this you know it i don't know if there's
like a head coach in the history of
football who supports his
uh you know his assistant coaches more
he's famous for it he will have some
answers i think he'll put the pressure
on some of these owners to go like what
the hell what are you thinking you hired
that guy and not him how could that
possibly be and then mike you're
thinking about the you know the playoff
coaches and wait till it's all said and
done too i think that's real too i think
the nfl needs to go back and reassess
that i don't think it's any like you
know
uh what do i want to say i don't think
it's a coincidence a guy like robert
sala now this year when they don't make
the playoffs is more impressive in the
meetings and gets hired this year and
you might go why i don't because of
everything eric b enemy just said he you
know monday night all of a sudden oh i
got to get ready for an interview i've
been more worried about my team and my
job right now i'm trying to win this
game so maybe some of those details in
the interview process get lost because
oh i just worked a 20-hour day coming up
with a game plan for a game now i got to
figure out you know my resume and crap
like that to where i got to impress some
owner with some bullcrap charts and
things like that that to me is a as a
disadvantage to these coaches who are in
the playoffs
and it creates divided loyalties and if
you do what you have to do to put your
best foot forward to get a head coaching
job you necessarily undermine the job
that you have to do for the team that
you're working for so there are many
issues that the league needs to take a
closer look at to improve this hiring
process because it is flawed in many
ways and i didn't mean to single out
david culley i mean you could look at
some of these other guys who got jobs
and say how do they get it instead of
eric bien i mean right siriani based
upon due respect the press conference we
saw friday i still like was that was
that big communication was that real was
that like was that you know uh but uh
uh and at the end of the day
the teams have to decide who they want
and clearly they are
hiring who they genuinely believe
is the right candidate for them i just
don't know that the procedures and the
processes when we just consider the fact
that these billion dollar businesses
don't bring in a consultant to help
their coaches prepare to deliver a
two-minute message at a press conference
what other flaws do they have in how
they operate this business that aren't
obvious what flaws do they have and how
they go about selecting their coaches so
these are all things that that i think
the league needs to address the teams
need to address and uh you know the good
the good teams like it chris that there
are some teams out there that that keep
making mistakes oh they love them to win
football games against the teams that
keep making mistakes yeah i mean
i get comments from
coaches and people all the time you know
good thing this guy's in our division
glad he's you know glad we're coaching
against him twice a year glad he's
picking the players yes i mean that's
part of the competitive nature and
things that go on behind the scenes in
the nfl but the eric b enemy thing to me
is still just mind-blowing you know i'm
glad he didn't take the houston or
eagle's job i think i i wouldn't want to
mess with that right now we know the
jaguar job wasn't there to be had
because of urban meyer but uh i i just
if eric b enemy's not a head coach by
next year there's a real issue
but you imply he was offered the houston
or philly job we've had nothing i know
he was gonna go with those jobs i'm just
glad he shouldn't have taken him but he
was offering him
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports